[Music]
all right so um I'm going to show you
how to get started working on shiny for
python apps so this is our website at
least the website in its current state
uh it will be changing in the future you
don't have to install Python and install
shiny and you know set up a virtual end
and all that sort of stuff that you
normally do for uh for developing python
code
you can just go to our website and click
on examples there's an examples button
here or it's in the bar up here so I
just click on that
and this takes you right into this
online shiny for python app editor uh so
we've got this app code here and it's
running the application over here and I
can make changes to this you can say
everyone
another click this button and rerun it
and the app is running right here no the
really cool thing is that this is all
running
in the web browser so there's this isn't
running on a server and um you don't
have to worry that you know if you
change this code here it's going to
change something on our server this is
all running on your computer in your web
browser
so you can feel free to experiment with
things as much as you want
now
over here there's a whole bunch of
different examples that you can look at
so it just starts off in this really
basic one that has a slider and a text
output all right I can move the slider
and some of the stuff here changes
but if you want to see how to do other
things you can uh and explore the
features of shining you can look at the
examples from the side so another basic
example is an app with a plot
and it's asking me here like hey do you
want to discard all the changes to the
files because I've edited this app a
little bit
but um since I'm switching to another
example I'm just going to throw that
away and it again that won't hurt
anything anywhere it's just just in case
you wanted to keep the changes on your
computer that's why it's asking me
so here is an uh map with the plot and I
move a slider and this histogram changes
the number of fins
and uh just just so you know you can
make this a little wider there's a the
layout changes when it's really narrow
so uh this is a sidebar layout and
normally when the the screen is the
window is wide enough it'll show this
the sidebar content on the side but if
you make it narrow then it reflows it so
it'll be on top and that's so it'll be
usable on mobile devices we can look at
other uh there's other examples here I'm
just going to fly through some of these
so just to get some idea of the things
that you can do so
um you can have an app that lets you
upload files and it this shows the code
for for how to do an upload
downloads
I'll skip down to some of the inputs
uh
so there's a lot of input and output
components for shiny so this is a text
input and if I type some text here so
so
there this Tech input text gets used by
uh the server code here and it uh it
puts it it constructs the string and
returns that and then that gets rendered
over here all right so there's other
again there's other types of inputs like
an American puts similar to a text input
sliders
check boxes if I check it this
value difference true or false
checkpoint checks box groups so I can
select multiple items and it'll give me
a tuple
with all the selected items
a selective input so like the drop down
box
radio buttons
text areas so this is for multi-line
text input
and there's date inputs and date ranges
and uh customer that's where
it will hide it in the browser but that
value gets sent to the server
so that's some of the inputs so for the
outputs
um oh this is actually the same app as
the input because
you type in something and then it sends
it back to the it sends output back to
the um to the web browser so there's
actually two varieties of this there's
the text output and this is sort of
normal html text
the verbatim text output where it's
returns it as code or sorry code
formatted text
uh there's UI outputs which let you
display any sort of uh user interface
components as HTML this component here
this text input
is actually output generated dynamically
in the server and then sent to the
browser so that's
um that's the UI that's being sent over
and and plot outputs
so for the if you need to display tables
currently you can use a UI output and uh
see we've got a pandas data frame you
can have a generator table with a two
HTML method on those data frames but
hopefully by the you know in the near
future we'll have a proper render table
output you know there's other fun little
things here like like different there's
a couple different layout examples and
some examples how to use various
reactive components and then there's
some more uh Advanced applications that
are uh put various things together so so
here is a Wordle application that's uh
written for shiny this is one that can
use if you if you load this on your
phone you can use your phone camera for
input and it can do image processing
something that lets you explore
different types of visual Illusions and
play with the parameters this is using a
python package called pylusion
uh and so on so there's all these
different these different types of
examples over here now let's try to
build an application so let's say we
want to explore a data set and we can
use the polymer Penguins data set that's
a that's a really it's a fun and
interesting data set to explore so there
is a python package for this and we can
just try this out from here from this
interface so I'll just go to this app
with plot just so that I'm
have a app that looks or that's
structured somewhat like what I want uh
what I want to do with this polymer
Penguins data set I'm just going to type
some code in here just to to see if to
try it out to see if it works so it's in
a package on Pi Pi called plumber
Penguins and the first thing that I want
to do is see can I install that package
here in this uh particular setting where
we have shiny running on python in the
browser we can use a lot of python
packages
um but not all of them so so if you want
to find out if your particular python
package can work here uh we have to use
something called micro pip uh that
that's
specific to
piadite which is python in the browser
so what I'd say is import micro pip
and micro pip dot install
mirror penguins
now I've typed it up here this is the
code editor and I can run it I can take
this uh I can use this editor and run it
line by line down here or I can select
the text and just run it all the blocks
if I select text I can hit command enter
and it runs it down here
this is our python this is the python
console and uh
it looks like it installed it so let's
say import from our penguins
okay yeah so it installed it and then
now I imported it and I can I could do
stuff with it so that's the first thing
I need to do to see if it will install
what I can do now is I can say click on
this button so I can this will open the
project files that are currently open
in a new window
okay so this is uh there's only one file
it's just this app.pi and
um it's open in a new window here and I
can edit this here but still go back to
this
uh this window this tab and browse the
examples
let's take a look at this polymer
payments data set first so
um
I'm just copying in patients in code
from Palmar pendants website
on GitHub
so if I just
load all this stuff like this so again
I'm running it in the console here so
that I can explore with the I can
explore the data a little bit before I
go back to the app and actually try to
put this code in the app
so Penguins is
load penguins and then take a look at
that
okay so this is a data frame with a
bunch of columns and 344 rows you know
what why don't we just try putting a
plot in here so we have this histogram
from this other thing that you know from
the example and let's just try replacing
it with some uh
the plot from from the Penguins data
okay so this is all let me move this
import stuff all the way to the top here
[Music]
I will load
stuff okay in here I'm going to replace
that plotting code
and let's see here so let's try putting
in a histogram
turn G
so it's so I've edited my app and I can
just hit the play button there and rerun
it okay here are the pellet list has the
wrong number of Colors Let's see that is
because I played with that a little bit
before I pasted it in there
let's try this again
okay so here we have a histogram of
these different penguins so the three
different species of penguins and
um and their body masses so we can see
that there's a lot of Adelie penguins
and they tend to be smaller than the
Gentoo penguins
um and there's also chin strap Penguins
uh
look like they're
roughly the same distribution of body
mass as the adult ones so that's kind of
interesting the reason the colors are
funny is because they're
semi-transparent here and this is
they're they're overlaid on top for each
other
but um let's say we want to explore the
histogram for each species individually
let's try filtering out by species and
creating uh creating an input that lets
you choose which species you want to see
the the histogram for
okay so in order to do that let's take
this uh we don't want we don't need the
slider anymore
um we don't need this text output
so instead of the slider we want to add
a UI Dot
input select and I'll call it species
and this is our label here choose
species
and I'm going to refer back to the
examples just to see how this works
because
um you know I might have trouble
remembering it off the top of my head
how to use the select input
so yeah we don't need that
so
actually you know what I should do is
I'll just copy and paste this so I'll
take this
let's select
instead of typing in there I'll just
paste that there and I can I can modify
how I see fit so again we're going to
call the species
and
[Music]
so on the left here of each of these uh
key value pairs this is the this is the
key this is what we'll use it'll show up
in the code down here and this is the
text that will be displayed in the
browser
so
but I'm actually going to use a shortcut
so I know that you don't actually have
to do it that way if you want those the
label and the value to be the same you
can just say the deli you can give it a
list instead of addict there uh tend to
chin strap
and now if I want to filter out use this
input to filter out the data I can do
something like
this I can say let's call this my filter
data I'll call it P equals penguins
and uh
equals input dot species
and then I have to put parentheses there
because I'm I'm invoking this as a
function so this input that species that
that corresponds to
this species up here
that's how I fetch the value
okay so then I'll take this is I'm just
storing this in P so I want to plot p
and if I hit if I run this app
I'll get the error the palette list has
the wrong number of colors because
there's three colors here but there's
only one one species of another filter
so I think I'm just gonna try to
commenting that out and see if this
works so that was uh I used a key press
for that a keyboard shortcut that's
command slash but you can just you know
put a pound sign in the front
and here we go this is the histogram for
the deli Penguins let's see if this
actually works Gen 2 nice
and chin strap Okay cool so
one thing that's not so great about this
particular app is that the x-axis keeps
shifting and M the y-axis as well
so it's hard to compare them
across species here
but uh I won't bother trying to fix that
right now but you can see here that you
know this is a really nice way of being
able to explore your data interactively
and we did that by just starting with
the examples over here and just copying
and pasting code that we needed and I
can clean this up there's all this few
other things that were not needed
anymore because reactive calc and this
render text all we have all we really
need here is this plot
I used the Palmer Penguins data set but
I actually installed it manually using
micropip earlier it's continuing to work
because it's still running the same
python session where polymer pagans was
installed but if I were to take this and
open this in a new window
let's see what it does this is a new
python session that doesn't have polymer
Penguins installed and
it says there's an error starting app no
module named polymer Penguins there's a
way to fix that let me close this
and that's by adding our
requirements.txt so that's it's the same
uh same format as what you'd normally
use in Python so I'd call it
requirements.txt and I create I clicked
on this plus to create a new file and
then I renamed it up here that starts
with them but it starts with by default
with some python content in it button
let's delete that
and I'll just say Palmer
uh Penguins here that should be all that
I need and now I'll try opening it again
in a new window
and because it's in the requirements.txt
when it when this app loads it'll go and
it'll install the package from Pi Pi so
and here we are it's showing it has the
data set and we can explore it and after
I've been working on it you know I might
want to save the work that I've done so
I can do that by clicking on this button
save all project files to disk now this
is currently only supported in Chrome
and in Microsoft Edge browsers it
doesn't work in Safari or Firefox right
now but I'll show you what you can do if
you're using those browsers so I can
save this save all project files to disk
that'll ask me if I'm sure I want to do
this
and then I select a directory on disk
I'll just create a new new directory for
this I'll call this penguins
[Music]
create that and I'm selecting the whole
directory so not individual files so I'm
in the direct the directory that I want
which is called Penguins hit select and
it saved the files there
so in the future if I come back to this
uh this editor or the examples page let
me just
up another
editor here
and this it starts with the default
basic app but if I want to use
oh if I want to load my previous work I
can just click on this one
this button here to load a project and
it'll ask me if I'm sure I want to do
this to close all the current files and
I've selected the Penguins directory
and there it loaded the files
um
it would have been a different order up
here but they're all still here and it's
running the app now if you are using the
Firefox or Safari another thing you can
do is just click on this download button
and this will download the file to your
download directory and if you if there's
multiple files that'll put them into a
zip file and then it'll just
I just saved it there
all right so after you've been working
on this app and
um
you know you've got something cool you
want to share with somebody you can
click on this share button here this is
this creates a share link and with this
URL here I if I click on copy and then I
can send this to somebody now it's 937
bytes long so it's a reasonable size
it's not too big
um and if I paste it up here
somebody else can visit this URL and
they get this same interface where they
can edit the code and uh and see the app
running over here or
you can just copy this application URL
which is just the app by itself running
by itself without the editor and the
terminal down there
and I'll paste it here
and here it is here's my app
just running by itself again that whole
thing is just encoded directly in the
URL so for this particular case
uh you know we're using some packages
like Seaborn and pandas then these ones
are included with our distribution which
includes shiny and uh it's built on top
of piadite but with Paul because we had
had to add polymer Penguins to the
requirements.txt it actually goes and it
fetches that from the Pi Pi repository
so every time somebody who visits this
website this this URL it has to go out
and fetch that package so just just bear
that in mind so let's say I've shared
this application with somebody and you
know they want to experiment with it
right in this win in this tab I've
loaded this app from that URL and let's
say let's just say I'm another person
who's now playing with this code so you
know and I'm looking at this I'm like
this stuff isn't necessary here let's
let's clean that up let's change the
text a little bit like
say which
penguins are your favorite
all right let's delete that oh and let's
clean up this palette thing because we
don't need that anymore we can actually
there's also a button here to reformat
the code
so let's just do that to make it look a
little cleaner and nicer and hit play
okay so which penguins are your favorite
somebody else can play with it uh make
some changes and they can click in the
share link and it again encodes this app
code into the URL and then they can
should pass it on to somebody else
so let's do that let's load that here so
all that extra code at the top is gone
and uh that commented out part is gone
and it says which penguins are your
favorite you can explore shiny this way
again you know
you can edit it you can go back to the
example browser to see if you want to
try something different like you know
instead of select input I want to do
radio buttons you know functionally it's
they're very similar
but the interfaces is different the user
interface is different but let's you
know let's just put that here and put
radio buttons I think this should just
work
yeah so you can just choose a deli Gen 2
chin strap it does the same sort of
thing
and you can look at other examples to
see you know to try different things
like if you want people to be able to
upload data
they can you can look at this example
if you want to fetch data from a remote
API there's another example here that
shows how to do that
so you know you can yeah you can fetch
data and put it in your app and you can
go back and forth between these examples
here and the code that you're editing
which is over here now all right and
after you're all done with that you can
you can save your work
um and work in a normal python
development environment we have python
installed on your computer and shiny
um and then you run it you run shiny
from the command line
and that will that will actually that
allows a greater range of things that
you can do than when you run it in the
browser
but running in the browser is a really
nice way to just get started and try it
out without having to you know go
through the trouble of installing a
whole bunch of packages